president Trump is encouraging
harley-davidson owners to boycott the
company if it moves manufacturing
overseas to avoid tariffs the president
tweeted yesterday that the US will soon
have a level playing field or better
until then American manufacturers are
finding ways to keep going Nancy Cordes
is on Capitol Hill Nancy good morning
good morning and some manufacturers here
in the US are getting hit twice first
when they import raw materials and then
when they export the final product as we
learned on a recent trip to South
Carolina where some lawmakers are now
being urged to take action South
Carolina Republican Tom Rice's home for
August recess those tariffs are taxes at
each of his town halls we attended the
same issue came up trained if it needs
to be corrected we all agree with that
South Carolina is where farming meets
manufacturing BMWs Spartanburg plant is
its largest in the world
dozens of auto part manufacturers have
sprung up around it this is the raw bar
that has the 25 percent tariff on it
Darrell Kidd is the sales manager at MSI
in Rock Hill where they build forklift
components using Canadian steel the
president imposed tariffs on that steel
in June which drove up the price we had
to evaluate and actually pass on about a
15 percent increase to our customer base
so your customers are paying 15% more
than they were before correct here in
the US here in the US recently South
Carolina's Chamber of Commerce sent a
letter to lawmakers urging them to do
whatever it takes to inform the
administration about the jobs at risk
due to rising tariffs but currently five
of South Carolina's six GOP congressmen
are backing the president rice is one of
them it's not free trade if you're
standing and letting the other guy
stick it to you he argues that US
pressure will eventually force China and
Europe to drop high long-standing
tariffs on US goods this is the classic
example of short-term discomfort for
long term gain in the meantime MSI has
applied for a waiver from the tariffs on
Canadian steel could you use us made
steel well right now we can't because
there is no u.s. supplier that gives us
the kind of material that we use and
with the president considering more
tariffs on Chinese goods China recently
struck back increasing its tariffs on
foreign made cars to 40% a move that is
designed to hurt us auto manufacturers
like BMW right there in Spartanburg
South Carolina
Alex Nancy thank you